what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna do a
podcast today can we swear this podcast
okay let me ask you this
can we swear can we swear we swear we
are we recording already Ariane Ariane
NPR joke so come around with how close
you can be to the audio stamps.com is a
great sponsor
yeah we're gonna do a podcast this is a
topper war tier request from Omni media
that is Michael beep he has this is all
going to be in the title of the video
because his question is with the flash
and development helm and the DC
properties being so inconsistent in
their adaptations do you think there is
just something inherent about the
characters in their world that makes
them harder to adapt
whereas Marvel has been much more
consistent across Sony Fox and Disney
with more successes than flops and a
boatload more films between them that's
interesting okay so I kind of took this
question a little bit more as you know
dealing with development hell because
there's a lot of films that are in
development hell quite some time Marvel
even has that quite often actually I
mean to to sum it up I would say not
really definitely you can't adapt those
DC care no it's impossible
I don't think there's something inherent
about the characters especially because
they proved that with Aquaman and Wonder
Woman two larger-than-life super beings
who are godlike characters they're able
to bring them to life you know you see a
lot of the times with the DC characters
people will often go towards that like
well they they deal a lot with like you
know godlike whereas Marvel characters
if you look at little characters like
star-lord Iron Man Captain America Hulk
they're they're humans who are given
powers eventually and then they're able
struggle with the power yeah whereas
opposed to you got like
Superman and Martian Manhunter you know
just got like the utmost power right
right then you got Batman who's like the
more granted one of them I was like just
a super sociopath
no I don't think this has anything to do
personally with you know Marvel
characters just being easier to adapt
generally because of the fact that
before the MCU became the MCU I think
that we were getting you know the DC
character adaptations were a little bit
more consistent and bigger and more in
the mainstream he had two very
juxtaposition characters between
Superman and Batman who are always
getting these adaptations well you know
you got to think that you know there are
beloved DC films beyond just what's
counted among the DC EU it's been proven
time and again throughout the different
phases of just the comic books trip to
the screen that proved that DC is quite
marketable you know and I feel like the
only difference is that Marvel when they
set up their studio especially cuz
because DC is is still just kind of
Warner a wing of Warner Brothers in
terms of movies right they don't even
like their own dedicated see this like
they do have someone who's like for the
DC Department yeah but they don't have
like DC studios the way Marvel has we
noticed you know there's a department
studio because I feel like if DC could
do that maybe the thing is Marvel just
seems to know the voice of their brand
and they knew really distinctly how they
wanted to transfer that to the big
screen and they kind of played it not
safe but they they took their time with
it as is everyone always says and I
think DC you know as smashed into Warner
Brothers and whatever this recent thing
is I think they need to really hone in
on yeah what makes their characters and
their types of stories unique because
it's like you can't mishmash somebody
else's business model into a completely
different flavor of world and characters
you know you know see what's funny about
that it's like the flash is raising all
these concerns I think with people but
I've already moved
past DC not knowing what they're doing
and I think a lot of people haven't and
I feel like I have like what do we like
you don't care like you feel like they
do now well if you look at what went
wrong all right like we all know what
went wrong we don't need to retread that
water again do people don't get it we
charge be Marvel too fast Justice League
go out there too quick
well you see Wonder Woman was amidst the
chaos of what was forming whether
universe they they dished out this one
great movie across the board called
Wonder Woman right and then they already
were filming Justice League when that
came out the ones they weren't filming
were Shazam and Aquaman yeah
so when Wonder Woman came out they kind
of went through this thing of like [ __ ]
we need to rework Justice League all
this craziness but once they got gold
with Wonder Woman they immediately went
to the drawing board of the film's that
they hadn't done yet hadn't started
filming yet which was Shazam and Aquaman
and even though I don't love Aquaman per
se it's a billion-dollar hit for a
reason as it responded great with
audiences not beyond DC fan speed like
most audiences seem to generally just
really appreciate the [ __ ] out of that
movie oh yeah and then Shazam was
another wonderful film so I feel like
they still Wonder Woman learn their
lesson but they were stuck with this
problem of Justice which is already shot
it was turning point and Justice League
was already trying to be somebody else
and I already and yeah and I'm a billion
times yeah I'm one of the people who
like the Justice League movie though the
weird mash-up of Whedon and Snyder and
I'm all for seeing the Snyder code
actually I would love to see that you
paid for those comic-con bus stops and I
did personally all my money
it's where the patreon money per diem
for hosting the panel towards yeah so
yeah I'm way past that part the flash is
one of those movies that has this weird
amount of control that I've never heard
of before
we're an actor like Ezra Miller who's
not [ __ ] like Tom Cruise yeah I know
he's like already in your career yeah
like look what happened at Norton it
he's been around whaling right yeah it's
a good comparison because that is where
my mind goes to it Edward Norton with
the Hulk who has way more you know of
clout yeah then at lunch as Remillard
does I'm like yeah Ezra Miller's kind of
popular he's likable but there's like
there's a lot of people where you say as
Remillard he's still gotta be like he
played this guy he was this guy
Creedence you know the guy who they
talked about but never talks justice Lee
and I don't know why he surprisingly has
this amount of leeway and control over
the way the film is developing into did
he get it like did he actually get his
vitae
you know make this movie well latest he
had issues with the script yeah and any
understand yeah a lot of this is usually
a bunch of talk that you know everyone's
anything and half the facts are true so
you have the latest I heard this is the
latest I heard right we are filming this
July 30th 20 1947 maybe there's some
updates I just missed all right we the
latest I heard was Ezra Miller didn't
like what was being pitched so he wrote
his own draft and that has recently been
denied to to be that was the last and I
don't know is John not John Francis
Daley the the guys who did the movie
that doesn't look like Tiger Woods
intact horrible Baz are they still
attached to this I don't know did well
you see the the thing about the
development hell property of the flash
specifically is they want to do
flashpoint and I feel like that's what's
putting them kind of in a conundrum is
flashpoint automatically lends itself to
being a very universe based movie
whereas they've been trying to steer
clear
that and do solo films and keep it
focused on that where if you do
flashpoint I mean I'm I'm I'm an
agreement with the idea that you can't
do flat you can't bend the rules until
you've established the rules you can't
toy with the world unless until you've
established the world so just it's kind
of weird to me like the flashpoint did
in that plot point wasn't from my
understanding didn't really satisfy
audiences but when they did it in season
three of the flash season three or four
I don't remember I did see it and I was
kind of whatever about it but when
audiences the the seasons to get there
yeah it was a TV show you just hop into
a story of flashpoint and then on top of
that it's I think that is the other
problem they're running into is that did
seem like they've been wanting to use
flashpoint as a jumping-off point to
reestablish perhaps a new Superman a new
Batman as a way to really help you know
how do we still keep gal gadot and Jason
Momoa but get a new Superman and Batman
yeah this is the way to do it and like
the Batman marries one seems to be
pretty intent on yeah it's something we
don't even know it's connectivity one
the birds of prey details are they super
universe based cuz that seems to me like
it's kind of off in its own corner too
like everything except flashpoint to me
sounds like it's kind of an individual
movie which is what makes me really
excited about what they're doing now and
I feel like also flash whatever that
ends up being is kind of a conundrum too
because it's this weird fulcrum where
there's probably not gonna be a cyborg
movie and so he's the remaining Justice
League character who hasn't had a movie
like there's one of them in 1984 and I'm
curious about how that's gonna keep the
continuity in order when Aquaman 2 is
gonna do but yeah it's like he's in this
unproven territory where he also has to
create some kind of pivot at the same
time yeah I mean that's just what
everyone's saying and I think it's not
unreasonable to assume that because of
the fact that it's its flash point which
entirely deals would time-travel then
things are turned upside down what if
they what if they ditched that idea
entirely and just did a flash movie I
feel like they would have it like that
I really think it
main issue is the fact that it's
flashpoint and I don't think enough
people are bringing that up it seems
like a like a bad time to try that after
the whole thing that just happened like
it seems like to do that with them seems
like they after all these movies are
announcing are in were the works that
seem like they've learned a lesson to do
flashpoint right now with the first solo
flash movie would be just yeah we're and
it's hard to bring the proper value to a
flat it's because the one thing is that
that you have with it at the time when
I'm pretty sure Warner Brothers DC
whatever thought that they had a great
thing on their hands it seemed like that
to do the idea of flashpoint would
probably be a lot of fun yeah but now
that they want to go just primarily keep
their stuff so low based doesn't really
work out and then so the flipside is
okay let's say you can flashpoint and
then you just do a flash movie well the
flash show is already pretty [ __ ]
popular yeah and seemingly pretty good
at being the fly and they've nailed
Barry Allen yeah and the whole like this
show is so far past the storyline of
Barry Allen's dad is framed it as in
jail and Barry's trying to figure out
how to get his dad out of jail they are
so far past that storyline and if you
last saw Barry Allen in Justice League
that's where his character was yeah so
what could you really do different then
the very popular show where you just go
well the show just does it better or
it's like yeah the effects are probably
a lot crazier and cooler and the movie
but it is just kind of like a remake
yeah and you see the thing is none of
the other characters that are getting
their standalone films have that issue
it's like I know them the fact that the
shows are separate kind of creates a
problem because you just lend yourself
to an instant comparison yeah you don't
have to make yourself very distinct and
justify being a movie yeah well but when
you see Justice League I'm like well
that's season one Barry Allen
and we're like literally way past that
heaven so do you think that the flash
should remain in development hell for
another five years would you like to see
them you like I think it would work best
if the show was cancelled but then it
looks like if the show gets canceled the
show
endures it can't you know yeah it's
canceled that might actually be worse
for getting out of Flash movie optigrill
people lozenger in the show well and are
people gonna have like a kind of Marvel
Netflix reaction where it's like oh
great well now they're just disavowing
the shows so they can go do these you
know new movie yeah I have I have no I
have no idea like movies are constantly
in development hell like that's not
that's no new thing no no yes movie is
an odd position and it's in like a weird
spotlight because just the light shining
on Wonder Woman Aquaman and anything
else DC has going on is just gonna get
on Barry Allen it's so yeah I'd I can't
the thing is we have no details as to
what they actually want to do with their
plot we just keep knowing what's not
working you said flashpoint and then a
bunch of directors keep coming in and
leaving and Ezra Miller seems
unsatisfied with the way the story's
going I don't know why he has so much
say I think he just wants it real bad
and it's like great he's gonna get cavil
door get don't get me wrong it's kind of
cool well it's kind of cool that they're
letting this actor playing the flash
have so much say in the treatment of the
character yeah yeah his storyline like
that's great it's just kind of
surprising that what's made Aquaman and
Shazam work and Wonder Woman was they
gave the directors free rein to do what
they wanted to do and the actors just
had to trust them and they did and they
turned out with wonderful films and the
flash is having this clash of visions
and a writer indirectly write and direct
and star in it hey my that's what I'm
like if you if you're the main thing
provide it seems like Ezra Miller's
vision is the main thing holding it back
okay that's just the buck see I don't
know this is just based off of
[ __ ] that gets thrown as hell over but
that's where my mind has luenell landed
is Ezra Miller seems unsatisfied with
what's going on yeah III get that I I
feel like there's a lot of that hanging
around anything that's not broken off of
Justice League yeah even I mean the the
Snyder cut hasn't died and has only
gotten strong like we're gonna see that
at some point like people have paid so
much money to voice that opinion like
it's gonna that's gonna come out at some
point
I feel like when Tom Warner Brothers
launches their streaming service that
makes so much money with no advertising
I would be awesome and it'd be a great
way to great platform to put it on yeah
I think you know you don't have to worry
about a theater release you're not to
worry about blu-ray releases but it's a
streaming service exclusive yeah and
then plus you know because Buffy ran on
The WB at some point sort of Firefly
they can you know and stick it to Joss
Whedon by just running ads for the
Snyder cut before every one of his shows
the estream yeah I think enough fandom
man can make a difference with these
development help projects you know like
Bill and Ted three is being filmed on
set photos and the fan respond
I think the key honest thoughts it made
a man a fan response of wanting a bill
and ted has dress I mean Alex winter far
exceeded the image so yeah I mean but
there's other like the crow is in
development hell for for know Jason
Momoa he's gonna do he's gonna do it
right I mean I found an article recently
I have it had it saved just in case you
like akira is another one yeah oh no
Taika Waititi he's the guy in like sam
man i I heard just got a Netflix got
picked up for Netflix and stuff I
believe that any time you say that
something gets picked up for a
fill-in-the-blank streaming series I
that is the new thing I believe might
just happen yeah anything that's like a
movies
suck in development hell like I have no
idea when we'll actually see the crow
and I don't feel like it'll be for a
while and it seems almost like at a
certain point they should just let these
things die
well DC is a lot like the DC Department
is a lot more careful than they used to
be if you noticed like they had no
presence at comic-con this year and
Joker Joker movie Joker movie is coming
out in October and we have one trailer
and it's and about to be August - of
information about how non comics
yeahit's
birds-of-prey supposed to come out I
think February next year I think
February next year and not even an
actual trailer has come out just vague
details and even with Aquaman that
trailer came out in July and the movie
had a December release so they're much
more careful now about like everything
that gets produced went to market when
to present I think they've been doing a
really good job and I think they just
need a son maybe any three in a row I
think yeah tip for people to be like
alright they've changed because some
people are still like yeah some people
are still stuck in the it's just
wonderful wonder them is when they
started changing the tide but then the
gnarly cream handling between that yeah
I don't know you had some bullet points
John have ie over shattered all them no
no no I mean that's basically I mean I
it's funny I thought this was a well
kind of happens stance to approach to
the podcast because I leaned just in
preparing for this more into the what
makes Marvel and DC different you know
the contrast of what the translation of
Marvel is to the screen versus what DC
is to the screen and that kind of honed
it on that aspect of what makes them
different and what hasn't been captured
recently or something and then you
leaned it sounded like more into the
idea of films that have been in
development so we don't have to spend
forever contrasting Marvel and stuff
like that but I don't know I mean the
the future of what they're doing is a
lot more exciting to me honestly in the
contained environment and I heard some I
you know just doing reading online and
stuff like that because I'm not the most
comic book savvy person so to flesh out
you know III heard somebody basically
describe it as like for Marvel if you
want to find like a great character to
keep on following like that's the the
company to go to if you want a great
story you jump to DC and so like I feel
I got the graphic novels yeah yeah yeah
and and you know there's something more
insular to me about the DC characters
struggle because it's true like like a
lot of the Marvel characters are people
like struggling with like having powers
and being a person and like normal life
versus and a lot of the DC characters a
lot more removed from that so you just
have a more isolated bubble with which
to examine the characters and also have
your cool connection stuff so like yeah
the the stuff they've been announcing it
makes me excited almost I feel like DC
could find a really nice space if they
don't try to do a whole bunch of
connected stuff for a while because that
actually does make me excited and it
means that they can explore and try out
a lot of stuff and go for the original
thing that they set out to do apparently
with their Cinematic Universe which was
to not do the Marvel formula and go for
filmmaker driven films you know and that
didn't work out in certain ways but it
did and others like you pointed out when
you they let you know patty Jenkins or
you know James Wan or you know David
Sandberg take over and kind of guided
you know you you got it's the perfect
blend between you pick somebody you know
can kind of come in and do their thing
and turn out a product you can rely on
but also somebody who has a vision and
yeah so like todd phillips i don't know
how much I trust him as an auteur really
but his movie sounds really exciting and
they're also characters I think that
they could be focusing on that people
don't know as much like when they were
booted the new 52 one of the characters
I heard about the most was animal man he
said like oh the current arc of Animal
Man is terrific and just in looking into
that and picking up a couple issues I
was like wow this is really cool so that
I feel like there are also other
characters who have other traits you
know that they could also go for instead
of having to have the same scale to I
mean you're always going to
have your big Batman movie you're always
gonna have your big you know flagship
stuff obviously but if they could play
the spectrum I think that could be nice
because it's also looking at Marvel's
plans you know they're changing again
they have big movies and now they have
their flagship unified television shows
coming up but maybe DC kind of carved
their own niche I mean they have their
shows and whatnot which don't seem like
they're gonna highly interact with the
world and I don't really know nobody
seems a hundred percent certain astute
future of the DC streaming network and
how that's gonna affect Warner and
whether it's gonna get folded into that
or whether it's gonna be two separate
entities but yeah I feel like DC could
make a lot of headway in doing a lot of
different scaled films and a lot of
different varieties and maybe also
bringing in some more interesting
filmmakers and some more obscure
characters yeah but I think Marvel has I
think the Marvel team Kevin Feige
obviously leading it yeah they've just
been better at navigating that simple
really yeah like they've had to readjust
constantly I mean we learned not long
ago that Joss Whedon throwing in Thanos
was just a fun thing that they ran with
and then made endgame and made it feel
like that was the point the whole time
no I just like when we think about like
Oh DC Marvel you got our Center very
different individuals running these
teams yeah and we don't know the extent
of how many people are actually involved
per team yeah it's why it's not just one
person is usually I'll falls on one
individuals I go exact Snyder [ __ ] him
or [ __ ] Star Wars you know ami Sony
but yeah and it's ours you know and then
and then Marvel is is Kevin Feige so
everyone just looks at them they're the
face of the team but there's a whole but
there's so much that goes into in Japan
working on this and give that goes into
the decision-making and yeah the
coordination between everything and and
I think it's easy I think it is it's
obvious because DC is not the only one
guilty of it it's very obvious it yeah
it's tried to start itself except maybe
the conjuring the
they just the Hat they didn't quite
understand what made phase one work so
well they immediately tried kind of
hopping to end of phase one beginning of
Phase two right away with all these
friends with all these things so it
doesn't even seem some I don't know I
don't know how these things break down
but again it seems like DC's film entity
right now isn't as autonomous as
Marvel's maybe gets to be in your
subject to also what Warner Brothers is
the studio needs to do and with their
bottom line eyes are so you know I don't
know it would be nice to see a future
word DC could just have its own studio
Marvel style but well guys what do you
think three are you excited for are you
excited for guy would have been great to
have one of these just on the top of my
head you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
tell us why you think the flash is stuck
in development hell